All right, welcome back to the show.
Let's let's hear from some folks.
It is the, I guess, sort of Thanksgiving edition
of live calls hitting us earlier this week
because we will be off on Thursday and Friday
for the Thanksgiving holiday.
We are taking calls via discord at David Pakman
dot com slash discord, discourse, c, o, r,
d and we have all sorts of different people
who are interested in chatting today.
Let's start with Andrew.
From Miami.
Andrew from Miami.
You're on the air.
Hi, David, how's it going, hear me?
Yes, I can.
Great, I was wondering what your opinion was
of remember when Bloomberg banned Democratic
primary?
Yeah.
He threw in like a billion dollars or something,
right?
I think it was I think it was a hundred and
fifty or two hundred million, certainly.
Oh, no, I think reporting from Washington
Post, New York Times said it was around 900
million.
Oh, maybe it is.
Yeah, I'm not saying you're wrong.
I had not heard that number, but it's conceivable.
Sure.
And then during the actual presidential election,
you went through in about hundred million
in one state.
I found that interesting because he said that
Trump was an existential threat, secrecy and
didn't, and I think he said he was going to
do like everything possible to get Biden elected
and he didn't.
I mean, listen, 100 million is nothing to
sneeze at, obviously.
But for a guy with his wealth, he could certainly
have have put in way more.
For sure, and I think that's why people are
saying things like, you know, eat the rich
and whatnot, but I mean, I also saw even on
the Democratic side, like Obama only came
out around two or three weeks before the election
and then afterward, he has this book tour
where he's on every major news station.
Isn't that pretty interesting?
Yeah, I'm I find the Obama thing less surprising.
I mean, I think during the primary, Obama's
approach was clearer, which was he's not going
to get involved close to the primary or before
it's decided because he wants to be able to
credibly support whoever the nominee is.
And if he ends up, you know, endorsing someone
during the primary who doesn't end up being
the nominee, it could just hurt his ability
to campaign for them.
If you're right, that Obama was only on the
physical campaign trail for a couple of weeks.
But I think a lot of that was that there was
really no in-person campaigning being done
on the Democratic side for a while because
of the virus.
He you know, Obama did speak at the DNC, which
was remote.
That's less of a flag to me.
The Bloomberg thing, it's just like he was
obviously just dishonest about how involved
he was going to be and helping the eventual
nominee win.
He just lied.
Right, definitely cool.
Yeah, thanks for taking my question.
Appreciate it.
All right, Andrew from Miami, great to hear
from you.